all right Chris we spent so much time
talking about offenses and different
offenses and which offenses are going to
be better which ones are having the rest
of the league catch up with them let's
talk a little defense because defenses
may be better this year after some
acquisitions we've seen in the off
season and I want to start with the Rams
because the Rams are definitely a team
that we've been focused on excessively
as it relates to the health of Todd
Gurley whether or not Shaun McVeigh's
offense is already getting a little
stale whether Jared Goff is truly a
franchise quarterback meanwhile Wade
Phillips is still presiding over a
pretty damn good defense and AMA kansui
is gone LaMarcus Joyner is gone but
they've added Eric Weddle to play safety
and also Clay Matthews to rush the
passer he's that an upgrade is that a
net positive in your mind for the LA
Rams ah no I don't think it is no I mean
again I like Eric Weddle he gives them
some experience he's still playing at a
very you know high level but I don't
know if he's the player that LaMarcus
Joyner is at this point of his career
LaMarcus joiners in the prime of his
career and Clay Matthews yeah he adds
some some certainly some debt depth and
another edge pass rusher that's a close
one as far as swapping him out and his
value to anomic ensue listen I think
that their very best and Dhamma
consumers capable of me being more
dominant at this point of his career
like we saw in the playoffs when he
turned it on he played like one of the
better defensive tackles and all a
football so the Rams defense is really
good to begin with I don't know if they
made it that much better this offseason
I think it's about status quo yeah one
of the more intriguing stories isn't
writing to the Rams last year during the
regular season they traded for Dante
Fowler jr. at the deadline yeah because
they were exasperated within dhama
consumes and ability to rush the passer
and he never really lived up to what
they expected and even Wade Phillips
wasn't able to push his buttons to get
the absolute most out of Sioux on a
consistent basis that's one of the big
challenges for Bruce Arians and Todd
Bowles the head coach and defensive
coordinator respectively in Tampa this
year where sue will be once again
expected to play at a high level without
without that postseason chase really
giving him the extra level of motivation
but you know something that Clay
Matthews said lies
week about Philips in his defense yeah
and and this is what great coaches do
when you have great players you find
ways to let great players make plays
that's what he's gonna do with Matthews
and that's good at what he's gonna do
with Weddell maximize what these guys
can bring to the defense and and don't
be so so tied to your system that you
lose sight of the flexibility you can
apply to showcase great players when
they come your way he'll find a way Wade
Phillips he always does whether it was
von Miller DeMarcus Ware you know years
of the Houston Texans he will find a
creative way to use clay Matthews and
the good thing for clay matthews too is
i don't expect him to be an every down
type player you know i don't know how
they're gonna orchestrate their
defensive line but either way they've
got other guys that can come off the
edge to to where you know he's gonna be
fresh when it's his opportunity to get
after the quarterback or whatever it may
be because you know some year you know i
don't know they're gonna go Dante Fowler
and Michael brokers a defense end like
they did last year where clay Matthews
is just like a situational nickel nickel
pass-rush parts you know some type of
defensive end I mean I think that's how
I envision them being used more than
just an every down you know in the
trenches type D lineman at this point of
his career
same division San Francisco 49ers
another team where we're so obsessed
with the offense but with the arrival of
D Ford they gave up a twenty twenty
second round pick to get him after the
Chiefs had tagged him that trade brought
forward to San Francisco and then with
the second overall pick in the draft
Nick bosta the younger brother of Joey
Bosa joins the team that pass-rush
beefed up in San Francisco is you know
and look I'm a firm believer that if
you've got great pass rushers Chris you
or I could play in the secondary it
doesn't matter at that point if the
quarterback doesn't have time to set up
and throw know and the 49ers defense was
a handful last year great improvements I
mean really and I expect them to be a
top 10 defense in football this year
their defensive line but DeForest
Buckner and Arik Armstead and now you
got
whoa you got d forward and Bosa coming
off the edge I mean that's serious and
they have pretty good depth behind it as
well so they're gonna be able to send
waves out of you let's not forget they
got Kwan Alexander a middle linebacker
that's gonna help replace the fact that
they you know Rueben
fosters not they're gonna have their
their version of a Bobby Wagner who can
just fly around the field
I think this 49ers defense is gonna be a
force to be reckoned with this year
too much of our pressure has been on
that 49ers offense the first two years
of the Shanahan regime it's always they
got a score and put up a lot of points I
think this is a year where the defense
could maybe win them some games 22 17 or
something like that but I they greatly
improved their defense this offseason
you know the fact that Jimmy Garoppolo
wasn't on the physically unable to
perform list at the outset of training
camp was the headline Quan Alexander not
on puppey either after tearing his ACL
during the regular season and all the
money they gave him the risk they took
financially paying off so far with
Alexander healthy and ready to learn
that defense and one more name to keep
an eye on former Chargers defensive back
Jason VI they love this guy he had an
Achilles tear if he's healthy he could
shake up that secondary in San Francisco
yes Mike I'm glad you brought him up I
didn't want to keep going down the list
of names here but when Jason Verret is
healthy he is one of the best pure
man-to-man cover corners in all of
football but he's been injured a lot
through his career so if he can stay
through pre-season in the season healthy
that I mean that's only gonna make that
secondary that meant that much more
dangerous the team with the best offense
in football last year the Kansas City
Chiefs has a defense that was last year
not very good but it's not gonna take
much improvement for the Chiefs defense
to balance out that fantastic offense
and this year the arrival of Frank Clark
who ended up being the guy they picked
up after trading D Ford because they
think Clark better fits the 4-3 defense
that Steve spagnolo the new defensive
coordinator is implementing you throw on
top of that Tyrann Mathieu one of my
favorite players of all time in the NFL
the leadership he brings the skill sets
he has that this could be with spagnolo
there and these two guys this could be a
much better defense in Kansas City and
it's not going to take much to propel
the Chiefs that next step beyond the AFC
Championship yeah you're right I mean
they just need a little defense right we
just can't have the worst defense in
football and I do I think spagnolo is
gonna be a great improvement for that
defense but the talent and the things
they did on the defensive side of the
ball first off Chris Jones is still
they're right Chris Jones's in the
conversation for best interior pass
rusher in football not named Aaron
Donald I mean him Fletcher Cox Hakeem
Hicks I mean he is special so you got
him in the middle of the defense but
getting a Frank Clark you know getting a
Manuel agua and that trade for the with
the Cleveland Browns signing a guy like
Alex L cavour I'll and then you'd
mentioned Tyrann Mathieu in the backend
but I like what Kansas City did upfront
you know D Ford's a small pure pass
rusher type Justin Houston good but not
great anymore not the guy he was a few
years ago these guys can do everything
Mike that's what I like it's a little
New England II where they can be they're
gonna be able to move everybody around
acqua could play defensive tackle or
defense end Frank Clark same thing he's
talented enough to kind of do both as
well so I kind of like the system and
personnel fit more now in Kansas City
than I have in years past I I think
they're gonna be greatly improved when
the Browns took Denzel Ward instead of
Bradley Chubb in the 2018 draft one of
the reasons given for the move was they
really like emanuel log but well as you
mentioned he's gone and one of the
reasons he's gone olivier vernon was
acquired via trade also Sheldon
Richardson signs with the Browns as a
free agent another team that we're so
focused on Baker Mayfield and odo
Beckham jr. and Jarvis Landry Nick Chubb
Kareem hunt Dave and Joe ku but that
defense sneaky great potential in
Cleveland and Vernon and Richardson
really beefed up a front for that's
gonna be headlined by Miles Garrett the
number one overall pick in the draft in
2017 yeah that's right and I mean you
know I maybe I'm wrong here maybe you
correct me but I'm pretty sure I got
this right I mean this is I think the
what 3 Pro boulders on the defensive
line I don't know if there any defensive
line in modern history's had 3 Pro
Bowlers on their d line at the same time
that's kind of special right there when
you just talk about Garrett Richardson
and Olivier Vernon Olivier Vernon has
not lived up to the money he got from
the New York Giants when he was a free
agent leaving the Miami Dolphins but a
really awesome all-around football
player and again like we talked about
with Kansas City you know hey the guy
they got coming in there Steve Wilkes
from the Arizona Cardinals he's a hell
of a defensive coach he's gonna
implement that Carolina Panthers
defensive scheme I
like you know this Cleveland defense let
alone you you know you mentioned you
know Denzel Ward being there in the back
end they got Morgan Burnett at safety to
help out that position a little bit but
man I looked at you know again the draft
the second round they got greedy
Williams greedy Williams still the best
pure cover corner in the draft for my
money it was more about tackling and you
know we talked about tackling a lot when
we talk about Deion Sanders and Darryl
Greene and Darryl Rivas very important
right very very that's what I talked
about with Jalen Ramsey too started off
you too I usually go he's he's tackling
I mean that that to me was one of the
dumbest things of the draft this year
the best Pierre cover corner dropped to
the second round because they didn't
know if he was willing enough tackler
you know then nobodies didn't even give
a damn as long as he just gets a guy
down during the season and he's covering
the other team's top one or two
receivers you know you're not gonna hear
anything about tackling and I think he's
very capable doing that I like what
Cleveland did on defense this offseason
and the thing to remember about Denzel
Ward he had some concussion issues last
year that way he tackles Greg Williams
who became the interim head coach and
was the defensive coordinator called him
out on at least one occasion for
tackling in a way that created that that
possibility of having a head injury or a
neck injury so Denzel Ward needs to
protect himself a little bit more but
he's got the skills and along with
greedy Williams this could be a special
team on both sides of which was awesome
product who do you get who do you think
what do you think one out of the four we
talked about like who do you thinks that
made the biggest jump it's a tough well
I think the Chiefs I think the Chiefs I
think the Chiefs because because Andy
Reid finally parted ways with Bob Sutton
because of the the arrival of Frank
Clark who I think was very underrated in
Seattle and and I'm just I'm a big
Tyrann Mathieu fan and I think he's
gonna you know I remember when the
Cardinals did the all-or-nothing series
a few years ago the Amazon series that
goes through the regular season that
there was a couple of scenes where
Tyrann Mathieu he just oozes leadership
and I think the defense desperately
needs that in Kansas
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports